نستمر معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه على
مدار الساعه للاحداث الجاريه في السودان
والاشتباكات بين الجيش بقياده البرهان
والدعم السريع بقياده حمدو او بقياده
دجل هذه المعارك مستمره لليوم الثالث على
التوالي بعد فشل جهود الوساطه المحليه
وايضا النداءات المطلوبه بخفض التصعيد
ووقف اطلاق النار هناك
[موسيقى]
الى ذلك نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني والقائد العام للجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان قوله ان الهجوم الذي شنته
قوات الدعم السريع في الايام الاخيره هو
محاوله انقلاب واضاف البرهان ان قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو تمرد ضد
الدوله واذا تم القبض عليه ستتم محاكمته
امام القضاء
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن التطورات وخصوصا في مدينه
مروي حيث هناك وجود لقاعده عسكريه مهمه
ومطار مروي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي نزار يعني بالساعات الماضيه كنا
نتحدث عن هدوء حذر عن ترقب للساعات
المقبله هل هناك اي خريق اي تحديث حول
الوضع الامني والمواجهات بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني
خلال نصف الساعه الماضيه شاهدنا هنا في
سماء مدينه مروي طلعتين جويتين او
تيندوتين
ضربه مطار مروي تحديدا المنطقه التي مركز
فيها قوات اعلى سريع شاهدنا ايضا مضادات
الطيران اتنطلق من ارضيه
ومخبط مطار مروي الدولي
باتجاه طائره التي كانت تحلق في سماء
المطار وقامت بقصف جوي لبعض المناطق
واستمعنا الى دوي والى صوت المضادات
واطلاق في المنطقه يبدو ان مقال به الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه بانه
سيمضي وفقه سيناريوهات مختلفه لاستعاده
هذه القاعده في هذا الايطار كنا النهار
هذا اليوم نتحدث عن
اشتباكات واطلاق للمدفعيه الثقيله الان
حديث يتط شيئا فشيئا
ليضم الطيران او يضم سلاح الجو الذي يشارك
لاول مره بعد اكثر من اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
على هذه العمليه العسكريه التي بدات هنا
في مروي وامتدت نحو عديد المدن في السودان
صعوبه حسم يعني المسار العسكري فقط على
الارض وبالتالي لجا الجيش الى استخدام
سلاح الجو استخدام سلاح الجو في يعني
ناحيه خطيره جدا وهي استهداف المدنيين هل
تم اخطار المدنيين الموجودين بالمناطق
المحاذيه للمطار والقاعده العسكريه
بالاخلاء هل نزح جميع السكان وهل هناك اي
معطيات عن يعني اصابات بصفوف المدنيين
لم يصدر اي
ان هذه العمليات دائما لا تتم بصوره علنيه
اي ان السلاح الجو لا يقدم لانه في
التوقيت المكاني او في الساعه
الانيه سيقدم على هذه العمليه لم تكن
هنالك اي توجيهات للمواطنين بان يبتعدوا
فقط تم تنفيذ هذه الغاره الجويه التي بدات
في الساعه السابعه والثلث
ثم بعد ربع ساعه مباشره استمعنا الى اصوات
طائره حلقت في سماء المدينه وبعدها مباشره
اطلقت
الطيران وحدث الانفجار في وسط المطار وفي
وسط القاعده المواطنون في مروي معظم
البيوت اطفات الانوار الليليه واغلقت
الابواب وسالت حاله من الصمت في مدينه
مروي ليس هنالك حاله من النزوح ليس هنالك
حاله من مغادره
هنالك اصرار على البقاء في المنازل حتى لا
يثير حاله الرعب وسط الاطفال ووسط النساء
حتى بانه هو يوم الامس عندما سرق معلومات
بان طلع جويه يمكن ان عليها القوات الجويه
السودانيه لم يغادروا منازلهم عديد الاسر
غادرت لكن معظم الاسر في مدينه
نزار يعني
بالساعات الماضيه بالتغطيه معك كنت تقول
بان القوات قوات الدعم السريع انسحبت الى
نقطه معينه ثم عادوا الى محيط المطار
ويعني الاشتباك دائر بين القوات بالامس
حصل نفس السيناريو انسحبوا عادوا بالليل
وعاده الاشتباكات يعني لتشتد بساعات الليل
اليوم هل نتحدث عن بسبب استخدام طبعا سلاح
الجو عن ساعات ليل صعبه على المدنيين
الموجودين بهذه المنطقه
بالتاكيد هذه الامور
تظل حاضره لانه في ظل استخدام السلاح الجو
لهذه الوضعيه هي
القصف
الجوي من على البوت في مواقع وفق احداثيات
تم تحديدها مسبقا هذا ايضا يعطي مؤشر على
ان المعركه الان بدات تاخذ منحى تصاعديا
لكن الشيء الذي يطمئن بعض الشيء من انه هو
منذ ثلاثه ايام لم تمتد مساحه الاسباكات
العسكريه او العمليه العسكريه او الحرب لم
تمتد خارج اسوار المطار هي مازال داخل
اسوار المطار
السيطره على المطار السيطره على مراكز
الحيويه الاستراتيجيه التي يعتبر هذا
المطار احدى اهم هذه المراكز التي يصعد
طرفين للسيطره عليها
لكن بطبيعه الحال يتخوف المدنيين يتخوفوا
من ان تمتد تاثيرات هذه الغارات الجويه
على بعض الاحياء المتاخمه حتى الان الصوره
قد تكون
او غائبه ساعات الصباح ستكشف عن وضعيه
نتيجه هذه الغاره حجم الدمار الذي خلفته
هل ستغادر قوات الدعم السريعه هل ستصمت
لتواصل القتال من الداخل كل هذه التساؤلات
ربما سنجد لها اجابه خلال الساعات المقبله
وربما ايضا ستواصل القوات الجويه
غاراتها هي الان قامت بغارتين جويتين يمكن
ان تقوم بالسالفه والرابعه والخامسه الى
هذه المعركه نحن على الهجوم في الانتظار
نراقبه ونتابع كل هذه التفاصيل عن كثب او
حتى يعني الاستفسار الاساسي الان اذا محل
يعني ذهب الدعم السريع نحو نحو استخدام
المدنيين كدروع بشريه
بسبب تطور وتقدم نوعيه القتال مع استخدام
الطائرات نزار بحركه نزوح السكان هل رصدتم
اي حركه نحو مناطق المجاوره كيف كانت يعني
ايجاز هذا اليوم اذا صح التعبير
اليوم ليس هنالك من من حركه يمكن ان نطلق
عليها نزوح ما يحدث دائما هو تخوف لبعض
الاسر
العائلات تتخوف خاصه التي تتاخم القاعده
هنالك حي يعرف بحي الدوم وبعض الاحياء هي
قريبه ومتاخمه لمطار مروي الدولي هذه
المنطقه منطقه مروي هي منطقه لاسر ممتده
ولعائلات ممتده العلاقات الاجتماعيه هنا
جد مترابطه مع بعضهم البعض بسهوله وبيسر
يمكن ان ينتقل السكان في منازلهم الى
منازل اقربائهم وذويهم وعائلاتهم لا يسمون
ما يحدث هنا بالنزوح ما يسمونه بايواء
لمؤثرين الى ان تستعيد اوضاعهم مع عافيتها
وسلامتها وامنها ومن بعد يعودون الى
مناطقهم هنالك بعض الاسر رصدنا حركه تحرك
من مدينه مروي الى مدينه كريمه المدينه
المجاوره علينا ان نقطع الجسر ومن ثم الى
هذه المدينه حركه تنقل بسيطه لبعض الاسر
غادرت
لكن الحياه اعادت الى طبيعته الى طبيعتها
نهارا وبعد ان بدات هذه الغارات الجويه
ليلا قد يتخوف المواطنون ولكن حاله الهدوء
وحاله عدم التجوال
مدينه في بعض المناطق غد يجعل من خيار
التنقل عسيرا ويجعل من خيار البقاء في
المنزل هو الخيار الامثل والانسب
خيار البقاء في المنزل ولكن هناك هناك
حاجات يعني انسانيه ملحه ايضا في هذه
المناطق مثل مناطق اخرى بساعات الهدنه
التي اعلن عنها بعد ظهرها لسطاع المواطنين
الخروج
هل هناك نقص ابي المعدات الطبيه بالاغذيه
كما في مناطق اخرى ام انه يعني الوضع افضل
هنا تحرك المواطنون هنا في هذه المدينه
لقضاء احتياجاتهم الاساسيه
والشراء مستلزماتهم الغذائيه والمنزليه
وكل ما يحتاجون نحن الان في ادوار رمضانيه
حتى بعض الاسر
بالعاده السودانيه باخراج الافطار خارج
المنزل
ودعوه عابري السبيل لم يتخلوا حتى عن هذه
العاده السودانيه القديمه المتجبره والتي
تعكس كرم السودانيين في مثل هذه الاوقات
من شهر رمضان مدن كثيره اليها الحياه من
تاثرت فقط هي مدينه مروي لانها تضخم هذه
القاعده وتجاورها لكن مدن كريمه ومدن
الغرير واوسلي وعدد من المدن كنوري ومروي
شرق الدنقله وحلفا كل هذه المدن الحياه
فيها طبيعيه تماما هم يتابعون ايضا
ويستطيعون الاخبار ويسالون عن اهلهم
وذويهم لكن كل المدن تعيش حاله من
الاستقرار والامن عدا مروي التي تتاثر
بطبيعه ما يحدث من اشتباكات لكنها
اشتباكات تظل فقط محدوده في اطار القاعده
واطار المطار اسمح لي نزار ان اشير الى ان
اخر التحديثات حول عدد القتلى حتى الساعه
بهذا النزاع الدائر بين الدعم السريع
والجيش 180 قتيلا حتى الساعه اذا كان هذا
اخر تحديث لارقام القتلى جراء الاشتباكات
الدائره بين كل من قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
المشاهدين الصور المباشره التي نرصدها من
العاصمه الخرطوم من محيط قياده الجيش ومن
ايضا
مروي كل الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين
التي طبعا ما زالت مستمره حتى الساعه وهي
اشتدت مع ساعات الليل وطبعا هي تتمركز حول
المناطق الحيويه الرئيسيه التي يسعى فيها
الطرفان للسيطره عليها نتحدث عن المطارات
الرئيسيه ان كان مطار الخرطوم ان كان مطار
مروي والمطارين يحتويان او يحويان قواعد
عسكريه مهمه
وتعتبر اساسيه في عمليه السيطره على الارض
وايضا مطار الابيض اذن الاشتباكات ما زالت
دائره
ولم يحسم اي من الطرف السيطره على اي نقطه
استراتيجيه حتى الساعه بالرغم من حرب
البيانات الدائره بين الطرفين
لا يزال مشاهدينا عشرات الطلاب محاصرين في
الجامعات والمدارس اثر المعارك الدائره
بجانبهم لكن ما يزيد الوضع سوءا هو تفاقم
الوضع الانساني بسبب قله الغذاء والماء
فلنتابع
تشتد المعارك بالخارج ويشتد الخنق على
هؤلاء طلاب جامعات ربما يتلقون درسهم
الاقصى تحت سطوه معركه حاصرتهم لعده ايام
ونجد جميع مبادره والمبادرات في الغاز
السريع الوضع الراهن لانه نحن لا يوجد
لدينا مؤن لا يوجد لدينا مؤن ولا يوجد
لدينا اطعمه وفضلا من
الطائرات تجوب تجوب في الخارج
ونتخوف نتخوف جدا جدا من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي
وانعدام المياه
هؤلاء ليسوا افضل حالا مضت ايام ثقيله
مراهقون لا تتجاوز اعمارهم الثلاثه عشر
عاما احتجزوا في مدرسه طالت دوام فيها لا
تهمهم قواعد الحرب بعيدا ولا هم مدركون
مناشدات عمت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لانقاذ طلاب الجامعات والمدارس والعاملين
فيها بعضها خلى من الطعام وحتى الاسعافات
الاوليه للمصابين
الهلال الاحمر السوداني اعلن عن اخراج 450
طالبا محاصرا من المدارس لكن يبقى العشرات
من طلاب الجامعات في وضع حرج بلا اي
مساعده
صمت المكان هنا بين الجدران تقابله معركه
على اشدها في الساحات
ففي احياء مدينه الخرطوم تستمر الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ما
اودى بحياه نحو 100 مدني واصابه 400 اخرين
وسط مناشده من نقابه الاطباء بفتح ممرات
انسانيه لنقل المصابين وتسهيل وصول
الاطباء الى المستشفيات غيداء السالم
العربيه
هذا ورصدت مشاهدينا الكاميرا العربيه مدى
الصعوبه التي تواجه سكان العاصمه الخرطوم
في الحصول على مياه الشرب والطهي بعد توقف
محطات المياه عقب تضررها بسبب الاشتباكات
الواسعه بين قوات الدعم السريع من جهه
وبين الجيش السوداني من جهه اخرى في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
ولا ما سامعين
ضرب مكثف شديد
فينا اتجاه اليمين المعسكر به هناك بين
الحراريه والبيوت دي
حضري متبهدل من هناك
مربع سته
حريقه كبيره شديد
اتجاه المطار والقياده العامه تحديدا يعني
مشاهدينا قبل ان انضم الى ضيفي ساشير
مجددا الى العاجل الذي ورد قبل قليل عن
تحديث اعداد القتلى 180 قتيل حتى الساعه و
1800 جريئه حتى الساعه اتحدث هنا طبعا عن
ان كل هذه الاعداد هي من صفوف المدنيين
جراء الصراع الدائر بين قوات الدعم السريع
وبين الجيش السوداني ينضم اليه بالاستديو
الدكتور اسامه احمد المصطفى الكاتب
والمحلل في الشؤون الافريقيه اهلا وسهلا
بك مجددا دكتور يعني اليوم
الاساس بكل هذا الموضوع طبعا بموازاه كل
صراع السلطه الذين نتحدث عنه هناك وجود
لحركات اساسيه مسلحه داخل الخرطوم والعين
على هذه الحركات اتحدث هنا عن مناوي مالك
عقار وجبريل ابراهيم هم الحركات الاساسيه
داخل الخرطوم هذه الحركات تميل الى
البرهان ماذا يعني ذلك في الوقت الراهن هي
تمرير البرهان باعتبار
هم يسمى المجموعه اتفاقيه الجبل السلام في
نفس الوقت هم
بشكل او باخر تابعين لحريه وتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه في حال
تغير مسار المعارك
واستطاع الجيش حسم المعركه في الداخل نحن
نتحدث عن انسحاب حميد وجماعته الى الى
خارج
العاصمه وبالتالي عن حرب مناطق مختلفه من
نوع مختلف اين ستكون هذه القواحينها في
الوقت الراهن وربما الى مسافات بعيده سيظل
هم صامتين لانهم هم حركات مسلحه في
النهايه والحركات المسلحه هنالك يعني
طريقه او محاوله ضم هذه القراءه الحركات
الى القوات المسلحه ان لم توافق هذه
الحركات للانضمام للقوات المسلحه المساله
راح تنفجر باتجاه اخر خاصه اذا كانت الحرب
اصبحت مناطقيه او جهويه ان كانت الان
معظمه
هذه المجموعه هي مجموعه معظمها طبعا غرب
السودان ان كانت بطريقه اخرى العاطفه
الجهه سيطرت على الطرفين هؤلاء الاطراف
ومع انسحاب
حمايه رغبه الصراع الدار بينهم وبين حماتي
وبين حركه الجهود في الفطر السابقه قد
المساله تتحول الى
نتحدث عن مشهد يعني معقد جدا وصعب جدا
وعن صراع لا ينتهي نعم اسمح لي استاذ ان
يعني ننقل هذه الصور التي نشرتها قوات
الدعم السريع في السودان وهي صور ليمروحيه
تابعه للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم والتي
اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع انها اسقطت
المروحيه بمضادات الطائرات
اذا مشاهدينا صور نشرتها قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان لمروحيه تابعه للجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم هذا واعلنت قوات
الدعم السريع انها اسقطت المروحيه بمضادات
الطائرات
اعود الى ضيف بالشجاع دكتور اسامه احمد
المصطفى الكاتب والمحلل في شؤون الافريقيه
دكتور بما اننا نتحدث عن استخدام مضادات
الطائرات وعن انتقال العمليه الان الى
مرحله جديده من استخدام الاسلحه شاهدنا
بقاعده مروي الجيش الان يستخدم الطائرات
بسبب صعوبه حسم المعركه على الارض مع ما
يعنيه من اصابه مدنيين اكثر وغيرها ولكن
عندما نقول بان الجيش يتفوق بالعتاد نقطه
قوه الجيش هي نقطه ضعف بالوقت نفسه بسبب
عدم القدره على استخدامه بشكل موسع بهذه
العمليه ماذا يعني ذلك بمساره المعارك نعم
نحن نعلم انه قوات الدعم السريه قوات
تتحرك بسرعه من مكان لاخر وفقي حرب
العصابات التي هما متمرسه بها تماما
يستطيع ان ينتقلوا من مكان لاخر ويستطيع
ان يتحركه في وسط المدن ولكن الجيش كما
اشرتي انت فان لها لديهم اعطاه قوي دبابات
وطائرات ولكن
قوه
نستطيع ان نقول هذه القوه هي في نفس الوقت
نقطه ضعف بالنسبه للجيش لانه الجيش لا
يستطيع ان يستخدم هذه الاليات الضخمه وهذه
السلاح القوي جدا في المدن
استخدموا الدبابات لضرب القوات الدعم
السريع وواسطه المدينه المساله بتبقى اكثر
ماساويه من ما نحن فيه الان عندما نتحدث
عن حرب بين جيش نظامي طبعا يعني اداء
الجيش النظامي بالحروب الداخليه اتحدث عن
حرب داخل المدن داخل الدوله وليس في
الخارج هو مختلف تماما عن اداء يعني قوات
الدعم السريع التي تعتبر هي يعني مجموعات
امتهنت حرب الشوارع هل هذا يصعب المهمه
اكثر ويسهلها بالوقت نفسه على قوات الدعم
السريع نعم
بشكل مباشر هذه
القوه التي يتمتع بها قوات الشعب المسلحه
ستكون هي بشكل مباشر ايضا نقطه ضعف لهم
لانه تحركات قوات الدعم السريع في وسط
المدن سيكون صعب على قوات الشعب المسلحه
ان تصل الى نحن الحد الان الطرفين كل منهم
يدعي بانه هو مسيطر على كل الاوضاع ايضا
هذا سيكون موقف حرج للوسطات كل جهات
الوساطات التي تحاول ان تتدخل عندما تستمع
لمستشار مثلا الرئيس
رئيس خارج البلاد وايضا الناطق الرسمي
باسم القوات المسلحه بانه كل منهما يدعي
بانه مسيطر هذا بالعاده تكتيك اعلامي
يستخدم يعني للروح المعنويه ان كان
العسكريين وان كان للتخاطب مع الشعب
السوداني موجود بالعمليات العسكريه اليوم
من يست حسم المعركه على الارض هو من يمتلك
استراتيجيه لكي يكمل مسار العمليات من بدا
بهذه العمليه العسكريه هي قوه الدعم
السريع هل بالتالي هم من يمتلكون يعني
الاستراتيجيه والرؤيه الواضحه
لهذا المسار او لمن سيحسم العمليه على
الارض اذا افترضنا جدلا بان قوات الدعم
السريعيه اللي كانت تخطط نحن فيه الان
فبالتاكيد لديها استراتيجيه بعيده المدى
لهذا الامر وايضا ان كانت قوات الشعب
المسلحه بقياده السيد البرهان ان كان هو
ايضا مخطط لهذا الامر دفنت لي او مؤكدا هو
يعني لديه استراتيجيه بعيده المدى خاصه
وايضا اكرر مساله صعب البساط من المدنيين
التيار الذي يبحث عن
الديمقراطيه في السودان
ونحن نعرف السيد محمد حمدان حميدتي اشارب
اكثر من مكان واكثر من اطلاله له بانه هو
مع الديمقراطيه وهو مع الشارع وهو المدنيه
في
البرهان لم لم ينطق بهذا الشيء بشكل مباشر
ابقى معي استاذ لو سمحت ساعود
لنطلع على ما يحدث على الارض هناك من مسار
العمليات العسكريه وخصوصا بالخرطوم بمعنى
نتحدث عن حرب الشوارع وعن المسار الدائر
هناك من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مشاهدينا
مراسل عربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم كيف هي
الصوره من هناك وهل يعني المعارك اشتدت مع
دخول ساعات الليل
نعم اهلا بكم بكل المشاهدين بدات بالفعل
هذه المعارك مشتده بعد الافطار مباشره اي
قبل حوالي ساعه ونصف او ساعتين اشتدت هذه
المعارك هنا في سماء الخرطوم هذه المره
وليست على الارض في السماء كانت هنالك
طائرات تحلق تتبع للجيش السوداني مجموعه
من الطائرات وكانت المضادات كذلك تنطلق
لمجابهه هذه الطائرات المضادات انطلقت من
ام درمان من محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون
وكذلك هنا من مدينه بحري من كافوري وكذلك
من جوار كبري شبات او جسر شنبات الرابط
بين ام درمان وبحري هذه المضادات كانت
تضرب هذه الطائرات الطائرات كانت تحاول ان
تضرب المواقع التي يتمركز فيها او تتمركز
فيها قوات الدعم السريع بعد هذا جاء الخبر
الذي وصل لنا ان الدعم السريع والاوقعه
احدى الطائرات التابعه للجيش السوداني
كذلك في المقابل الجيش السوداني يتحدث على
ان كل هذه الاخبار التي يتحدث عن الدعم
السريع
تكون كاذبه من بعض المصادر تابعه للجيش
السوداني اكدت ان هذه هذه المعلومات خاطئه
او مغلوطه لكن لو تبين اكثر من ذلك لكن
نعود الى الوضع الانساني الذي تعيشه
الخرطوم هذه الايام خاصه الوضع الصحي
الملف الصحي الذي فيه من جديد يعني الجديد
فيه الان بالضبط هو ان هناك مستشفى اخر
خرج من الخدمه وهو مستشفى بحري هنا في
مستشفى بحري خرج عن الخدمه تماما هذا ما
اكده لنا احد المصادر العامله في مستشفى
بحري وهو جزء من اللجنه المسؤوله عن
الاطباء في داخل مدينه بحري اكد لنا ان
مستشفى بحري الان خارج الخدمه تماما ذكر
العديد من الاسباب ابرز هذه الاسباب
انقطاع المياه عن مستشفى بحري انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي عن مستشفى بحري كذلك
ايضا عدم قدره الكوادر الطبيه للوصول الى
مستشفى بحيكس لاستقبال الحالات الطارئه
بالاضافه الى انه اكد لنا بانه بجوار
مستشفى بحري هذه المنطقه منطقه ساخنه يصعب
الوصول اليها بحكم انها منطقه اشتباكات
بحسب وصف هذا المصدر لكن بالمجمل نقول ان
مستشفى بحري يضاف الى مستشفى الشعب الذي
خرج عن الخدمه والمستشفى الدولي الذي رفع
ايضا انه سيخرج عن الخدمه خلال هذا اليوم
اذا ثلاث مستشفيات بحسب المصادر هي الان
ستكون خارج الخدمه تماما في هذا اليوم هذا
بالاضافه الى مراكز غسيل الكلى التي هي في
الغالب خارج الخدمه الان الان نستمع الى
هذه الاصوات اصوات مضادات الطيران يمكن
للكاميرا ان تتحرك لنريه المشاهدين هذه
المضادات التي تعمل الان كما نستمع اليها
الان مضادات للطيران في هذه المناطق التي
نحن فيها في منطقه بحري بالقرب من شمبات
والشعبيه كذلك اذا تستمعون لهذه الاصوات
في منطقه بحري اصوات مضادات الطائرات التي
ترى في سماء الخر طوم في هذه اللحظات بعد
هدوء عما لحظات الماضيه واللحظات السابقه
في هذا الليل او مع بدايه هذا الليل بعد
الاشتباك نعم تقول اصوات مضادات طائرات
بالتالي الجيش السوداني يستخدم يلجا الى
القصف بالطائرات وقوات الدعم سريع تستخدم
المضادات
هل ممكن ان هو بالفعل كذلك هذه المضاده
نعم يمكن ان نبقي صوره على هذه المشاهد من
منطقه بحري ونحن نشاهد هنا في هذه المنطقه
جزء من
مضادات الطائرات على ما يبدو اكمل لو سمحت
نعم هي الان هداتها بشكل بشكل خفيف طبعا
ربما تواصل كالعاده يعني هي تبدا في اوقات
وتختفي في اوقات لكنها تثير الرعب في قلوب
المواطنين هنا في مدينه بحري نحن الان في
منطقه هي الرابط بين
شامبات
الشعبيه بالقرب من هذه المناطق التي تنطلق
منها هذه المضادات في هذه اللحظات ايضا
نؤكد هنا ان هذه
العمليات العسكريه ما زالت مستمره حتى هذه
اللحظه وهذه العمليات العسكريه تستهدف
المواقع التي
يتمركز فيها او تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع سالم ماذا عن اخر التحديثات حول
العمليه العسكريه الدائره بمحيط مطار
الخرطوم الذي [__] قاعده عسكريه مهمه
والذي يصعب طرفين طبعا للسيطره عليه
ما زال هناك
الاحتدام القتال في تلك المنطقه لكن هدات
الاوضاع بعيده الافطار قليلا في تلك
المناطق لكن بحسب المصادر ان هناك
اشتباكات حاده في منطقه جبرا ضاحيه جبره
في الخرطوم ايضا فيها اشتباكات عنيفه بين
قوات الجيش والدعم السريع كذلك
سالم ابقى معنا لو سمحت طبعا ساعود اليك
خلال هذه التغطيه اعود الى ضيف الاستوديو
استاذ يعني تابعت معك ما يحدث هناك
استخدام الاليات الثقيله لان الجيش يعني
يريد حسم المعركه باسرع وقت ممكن ولكن
النقطه الاساسيه هنا بانه فعلا اذا ما قام
الجيش بحسم المعركه داخل العاصمه وقام
يعني بدفع بقوات تحميات الى خارج العاصمه
ممكن ان يذهبوا الى دارفور ومناطق اخرى
بالتالي نتحدث عن عرض من نوع مختلف وليس
عن حسم الحرب نهائيا هل نتحدث عندها عن
سودان مقسم
نعم انا اتفق مع هذا الراي باعتبار انه
اذا الان قرر حمايه يعني ينسحب بقواته من
العاصمه السودانيه بكل ما لديها من عتاه
الى منطقه غرب السودان
بالتاكيد
سيكون ذلك من اجل اعداد نفسه من جديد
وربما لخوض المعركه من مسافات بعيده مع
القوات الشعب المسلحه ولكن هذا قد يجعل
الفرصه جيده لقوات الشعب المسلحه باعتبار
انه سيكون الحرب خارج المدينه وبالتالي
يستطيع
القوه القوه امين عنصر القوه التي لديهم
قد يستخدموه بشكل صحيح عندما تكون قوات
الدعم السريعه خارج المدن
فالمفارقه كبيره ما بين الطرفين
خروج قوات الدعم السريع من العاصمه سيضعف
قدرته على الاستمرار في المعركه
وجود داخل العاصمه سيكون عنصر ضعفي
بالنسبه
للقوات الشعب المسلحه باعتبار انه نحن
الان
هاشمي يقول الهاشمي يقول انه هنالك مضادات
طيارات داخل العاصمه في منطقه جمره هذه
منطقه اهله بالسكان
كيف تم استقدامها الى داخل هذه المناطق
وبالتالي هم يعني حضروا لهذه العمليه
ساعود استاذ لو سمحت الى الصوره المباشره
والى الزميل من السودان لنقل الصوره مجددا
سالم اذا امكن ايجاز يعني المناطق التي
يتمركز فيها الدعم السريع حاليا في حال
يعني كان لديك ايجاز عن الموضوع
واين يتركز الضرب بهذا
التوقيت
بالنسبه للماكن التي كمركز فيها تتمركز
فيها قوات الدعم السريعه تفهم هذه المناطق
من مناطق الاشتباك نفسه ومن هنا يعرف ان
هذه المنطقه فيها قوات للدعم السريع فمثلا
في كافوري كان هناك اشتباك اليوم في ايضا
في كوبر منطقه كوبر كذلك هنا في
الشعبيه في الاتجاهات عفوا حله حمد امام
الشعبيه كذلك في ام درمان كذلك في محيط
هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون ايضا في الخرطوم
في محيط القياده العامه للقصر مطار
الخرطوم كذلك جبر ايضا وسط الخرطوم ايضا
هناك يعني يسمع ذوي للرصاص وكذلك المدافع
الثقيله كل ما تسمع هذه المدافع الثقيله
والرصاص في مكان او تبادل هذا الامر يعرف
ان هذه المنطقه توجد بها قوات من قوات
الدعم السريع عاده
ابقى معي سالم لو سمحت ساعود اليك طبعا
خلال هذه التغطيه ابقي لنا الصوره مفتوحه
لو سمحت
لنبقي رصد الاوضاع هناك ولنبقي الصوره
المباشره على الهواء مشاهدينا في ردود
الافعال الدوليه قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي خلال لقاء نظيره لبريطاني ان
بلاده تشعر بقلق عميق تجاه استمرار
الاشتباكات في السودان مؤكدا على اهميه
الاتفاق مع الحلفاء على ضروره وقف
الاشتباكات الدائره بنكن اضاف ان الشعب
السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين لسكناتهم
وان الشعب يتطلع الى دوله ديمقراطيه من
جهته دعا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني طرفي
الصراع الى اعطاء الاولويه للسلام لانهاء
الازمه
ثمه قلق عميق مشترك بشان القتال في
السودان والتهديد الذي يشكله على المدنيين
وعلى السودان وعلى المنطقه نشعر بقلق عميق
تجاه استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان نقشنا
هنا في اليابان الوضع في السودان مع حلفاء
في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا وهناك اتفاق
مشترك حول ضروره ان يعمل العسكريون على
ضمان حمايه المدنيين وغير المقاتلين وكذلك
مواطنين من دول اخرى لدينا وجهه نظر
مشتركه حول ضروره وقف القتال بالسودان على
الفور وعوده طرفي النزاع الى المحادثات
فالشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
للذكنات ويريد كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه
المحادثات التي اجيناها كانت واعده لوضع
السودان على مسار الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه
في وقت سابق اليوم اجرينا نقاشا حول الوضع
في السودان وقد تواصلنا مع اصدقائنا في
المنطقه العربيه وسنستمر في التواصل وفي
نفس الوقت اود التاكيد اننا نتفق مع ما
قاله الوزير بلينكن في الدعوه لوقف فوري
للعنف والعوده لمفاوضات تسير باتجاه انتاج
حكومه مدنيه وهذا بالتاكيد هدفنا الاكبر
وكلانا سنستمر بالعمل مع الولايات المتحده
واصدقائنا في افريقيا وفي العالم العربي
للوصول الى السلام والى ديمقراطيه مدنيه
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن هذه التصريحات
وعن
الدور الثاني بهذه
ينضم الينا من واشنطن حسين الطوب مراسل
العربيه حسين يعني من المعلوم بان البلدين
هما ركنين اساسيين بدول ترويكا وبايضا
اللجنه الرباعيه هذا ما تحدث عنه الطرفان
هل ممكن ان يضاف اليه اي مبادره بساعه
المقبله وما في تفاصيلها
تحيه لك ليال قبل ذلك الامريكيون منزعجون
من هذا التصعيد والقتال في الخرطوم وفي
مناطق اخرى من السودان كما صرح لقناه
العربيه متحدثه باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي الذي اكد على ان لا حل عسكري
للازمه السياسيه في السودان وقال بان هذا
التصعيد يهدد ما تم تحقيقه في المفاوضات
من اجل العوده لحل السلميه وديمقراطي
ويهدد يتطلع اليه الشعب السوداني ودعا هذا
المتحدث في تصريحات خاصه بالعربيه
القوات المتقاتله الى وقف الاقتتال بدون
شروط والعوده الى المحادثات طبعا انتوني
بلينكن كان صرح قبل ذلك بان هذا المحادثات
كانت لها تعطي املا باعاده او بوضع
السودان على طريق العوده الكامله الى
حكومه انتقاليه بقياده بقياده مدنيه
الامريكيون حريصون على استقرار السودان
كما يوضحون لان استقراره يؤثر على استقرار
المنطقه لذلك لا نستبعد
قيامهم بتحركات دبلوماسيه عديده تجاه هذا
البلد من اجل وقف هذا التصعيد الذي يحصل
الان كما كان ايضا لافتا تحميل
المجلس الامن القومي الامريكي القياده
العسكريه السودانيه يعني
مسؤوليه حمايه المواطنين
وحتى مواطنين من دول اخرى بمن فيهم
العاملين في البعثات الدبلوماسيه تحميلهم
مسؤوليه حمايه هؤلاء المواطنين وحمايه امن
البعثات الدبلوماسيه هناك من يشير ليال
بان لدى الاداره الامريكيه
مخاوف لم تعلن عنها من تكرار سيناريو ما
حدث مع السفير الامريكي في ليبيا عام 2012
لذلك
يؤكد المسؤولون الامريكيون انهم على تواصل
مباشر مع
البعثه الدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم يطمئنوا
عليهم طبعا هناك مواقف كانت سابقه بالنسبه
لاعضاء مجلس الشيوخ نذكر منهم
كبيره الجمهوريين في لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه الذي انتقد الاقتتال في السودان
وقال بان القياده العسكريه السودانيه لجات
الى حمل السلاح من اجل مصالحها التي وصفها
بالانانيه ووضعتها فوق مصالح المواطنين
السودانيين واعتبر بان
الفئات المتقاتله والموالين للرئيس السابق
عمر حسن البشير هم العائق الاكبر امام
الديمقراطيه في السودان طبعا المواقف في
الكونغرس الامريكي من قبل هذه الازمه في
الحقيقه منذ ازاحه الحكومه المدنيه في
اكتوبر عام 2021 كانت منتقده لهذه العمليه
ووصفت ازاحه الحكومه بالانقلاب العسكري
وكان هناك وهناك مشاريع لفرض عقوبات على
القياده العسكريه في السودان
الموضوع قد يتطور وقد يتفاقم اكثر لاسيما
انه اليوم عاد المشرعون الامريكيون الى
الامريكي قد نرى مواقف اكثر تشددا تجاه ما
يجري في السودان
بالانقلاب السابق
حينها اوقفت الامم المتحده الجهات الدوله
الجهات المانحه المساعدات
لداخل السودان لانها اعتبرت بان ذلك
انقلاب على المسار السياسي الكامل اليوم
مع ما يحدث وبالسياق الذي تتحدث عنه هل
ممكن ان نتوقع ضغط اكثر على الاطراف
السودانيه خصوصا ان الوضع الانساني هناك
والاقتصادي هو صعب جدا
بالفعل هذا ما نتوقعه ليال خلال ايام
القادمه خاصه كما قلنا بان لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في
عام 2021 وحتى 2020 كانت صوتت على فرض
عقوبات على المسؤولين العسكريين في
السودان بسبب ما تصفيفه بالانقلاب العسكري
الذي حدث في اكتوبر عام 2021 لذلك الامور
مهيئه بالنسبه لهم لفرد عقوبات على
القياده العسكريه السودانيه طبعا حتى الان
نحن نلاحظ بان جميع المواقف التي تصدر من
الاداره الامريكيه مواقف هادئه تستخدم
تنتقل كلماتها بدقه هي على حياد بين
الطرفين المتنازعين الان ولكن عندما نتحدث
عن الكونجرس الامريكي بمجلسيها الشيوخ
والنواب هناك مواقف متقدمه منتقده للقياده
العسكريه لطالما انتقدت هذه القياده
العسكريه ان كان البرهان او حميديتي
وتعتبر فعلوه في اكتوبر 2021 بانه هو
انقلاب عسكري ذلك اكثر من مره وصوتوا على
توجيه او فرض عقوبات على كل من يعرقل
الانتقال السلمي في السودان شكرا لك حسين
مراسل العربيه حدثنا من واشنطن مشاهدينا
سنتابع هذه الصور المباشره للعمليات
عمليات الاشتباك الدائره بين
القوات القوات الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في سلاح المهندسين في ام درمان
فلنستمع
على ما يبدو ان لا صوت حتى الساعه ولكن هي
الصوره عن اشتباكات عنيفه تدور بين
الطرفين
[موسيقى]
اذا
الشبكات عنيفه تدور بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني في سلاح المهندسين في ام
درمه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القاهره الدكتور
حسن ابو طالب المستشار في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه اهلا
وسهلا بك دكتور بما ان الحوار الداخلي
مغلق مقفل واصلا هو فشل يعني بالمرحله
الماضيه الوساطه هي الحل الوحيد اليوم بين
الطرفين في حال كان يعني محل قبول لهذه
الوساطه الوساطه اليوم هناك اطراف اساسيه
ممكن ان تدخل بها اتحدث هنا عن الاليه
الثلاثيه اللجنه الرباعيه دول ترويكا مصر
والقاهره وجباء من من هذه الاطراف هي
الاقدر اليوم على الدخول بواساطه ممكن ان
تكون محل قبول لدى الاطراف المتناحره
والمتحاربه
يعني في البدايه اعبر عن يعني حزني
والسياق الشديد مما يجري في السودان
الشقيق ويعني اؤكد على ان ما يحدث الان هو
يضر كل الاطراف حتى الاطراف العسكريه التي
تتصور انها تستطيع ان تنتصر على الطرف
الاخر ففي الاول وفي الاخير لن يكون هناك
منتصر حاسم في هذه المعركه وبالتالي الحل
الوحيد هو ان يكون هناك اساس معين يتم من
خلاله ما يمكن ان نسميه بتسويه بعض
الخلافات وايضا القبول بتنازلات مشتركه
ومتبادله حتى يستقل الوضع في السودان
وتنطلق الامور الى يعني وضع شبه طبيعي ثم
وضع طبيعي لاحق مساله المبادرات ومساله
هناك اكثر من طرف موجوده على الساحه
السودانيه منذ الفتره الماضيه لم تكن مصر
من بينهم الان مصر طرحت بالامس يعني تصور
معين لمبادره مع جنوب السودان وبالتالي
فهذه ايضا يعني مدخل جديد يجب ان يوضع في
الاعتبار لكن دعيني اقول ان المساله هنا
ليست مساله تعدد المبادرات تحدد الاطراف
لابد ان يكون هناك تنسيق بين كل هذه
الاطراف وان تكون هناك مبادره واحده فقط
ويتم الضغط بها من كل الاطراف التي تلعب
هذه او تتبنى هذه المبادره من خلال
التواصل مع الطرفين والنقطه الاولى
والاهميه الاولى هي الان في وقف اطلاق
النار والحفاظ على الموارد السودانيه
والحفاظ على ارواح السودانيين سواء مدنيين
او عسكريين الى اي مدى يمكن وقف اطلاق
النار هل ممكن ان يتم وننتقل الى مرحله
الوساطه في حال لم يستطع اي من الطرفين
تغيير موازين القوى على الارض خصوصا ان
يعني هذه الموازين ممكن ان يعني تعطي
اوراق قوه كثيره لاحد الطرفين على طاوله
الحوار
بالتاكيد ما يجري الان هو محاوله لتعديل
موازين القوى على الارض ولكن يبدو ان هذه
الموازين متقلبه وليست ثابته ويمكن للطرف
ان يطلب وضع معيننا في منطقه معينه في يوم
ثم ينقلب الوضع عليه في اليوم التالي
وبالتالي في هذا الامر يعني ان لا احد
يستطيع ان يحسم المساله عسكريا السودان
بلد كبير مواقعه كثيره انتشار قوات الدعم
السريع موجوده في اكثر من مكان في السودان
وليس فقط في المدن الكبرى ونفس الشيء
بالنسبه للقوات المسلحه ومواقعها العسكريه
وقوتها ايضا منتشره في الكثير من وبالتالي
فالعركه هنا ليست معركه مرتبطه بمنطقه
بسيطه او منطقه محدوده نحن نتحدث عن معارك
في اكبر مدن السودان وايضا مواقع متفرقه
وبعيده عن المدن الاساسيه والمطارات
والمرافق الاساسيه وبالتالي فالمساله هنا
هو من يحسم حتى لو استطعت اي طرف من
الاطراف ان يسيطر على بعض مواقف الطرف
الاخر ما الذي يحدث هذا الامر لا
لا يقدم كثيرا فيما يتعلق بمساله الحسم
العسكري الذي قد يتصوره سواء القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه او القياده
المتعلقه بالدعم السريع لكن الى اي مدى
يقبل الطرفان فكره الوقف اطلاق النار ثم
البدء بحوار هنا الاساس مهم جدا جدا جدا
في هذا الموضوع سواء المبادره المصريه ومع
جنوب السودان بتضع يعني اطار عملي في هذا
الموضوع بتراعي في الحساسيات وبطلاع في
ايضا التوازنات وبتروح فيه الحفاظ على
الموارد البشريه وعلى الموارد الماديه
للسودان والسودانيين وبالتالي هل يقبل
المهم حتى هذه اللحظه هو ليس في المبادره
القرار هو في الاطراف السودانيه نفسها
خصوصا ان جنوب السودان رعت اتفاق جبال
السلام ونجحت بذلك اليوم هل ممكن ان ترعى
اتفاق جديد بين الاطراف المتقاتله وتنجح
بهذا الامر وهل اذا ما فشل هذا الامر ممكن
ان يهدد اتفاق جبل السلام مجددا
طبعا حرص جنوبي السودان على السلام في
السودان مساله مهمه جدا جدا لان هذا الامر
له علاقه مباشره بالاستقرار وبالامن
وبالتنميه في جنوب السودان وبالتالي ايضا
نظرا للعلاقات التاريخيه ما بين جنوب
السودان وما بين شمال السودان يستطيع فعلا
جنوب السودان من خلال تواصلات ومن خلال
اتصالاته مع كل الاطراف ان يكون عنصر حيوي
ومهم في هذا الاطار جنبا الى جنب الاليات
المختلفه الموجوده في الداخل جنبا الى جنب
الدور والنفوذ المصري في هذا الموضوع
المهم انا من وجهه نظري ان يكون هناك
توافق بين كل هذه الاطراف على خطه معينه
وكلهم ينسقوا فيما بينهم من خلال ويمارسوا
الاكبر ضغط ممكن على الطرفين هذا هو
المدخل الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يؤدي الى
النجاح لكن لو راينا ان هناك اكثر من طرف
وكل طرف لديه تصور يختلف عن الطرف الثاني
في هذا الامر سوف يقسم الكثير من النفوس
والفعاليه ويقسم ايضا الكثير من الضغط
المقبول والممكن ان يؤدي الى نتيجه في
اطلاق النار الاولويه الان هي وقف اطلاق
النار والحفاظ على الارواح والحفاظ على
الموارد على ما يبدو يعني بحسب ما افادنا
زميلنا مواطن دول الترويكا اتحدثون عن
الولايات المتحده وعن بريطانيا ستتجه الى
ضغط كما تتحدث ضغط عبر عقوبات ممكن ان
تفرض على الاطراف المتناحره هناك ايضا مصر
بحكم علاقه التاريخيه مع السودان وبحكم
دور يعني
الحياد الذي لعبته بالفتره الماضيه ممكن
ايضا ان تلعب دور اساسي بهذا الصراع جنوب
افريقيا كل هذه العناصر متكامله مع بعض هل
ممكن ان تؤدي الى ضغط حقيقي يوقف الاقتتال
الداخل الدائر داخل السودان اذا يعني ما
بقي الاطراف المتناحرين على موقفهما
في البدايه يعني احب ان اعلق وان اتحفظ
على فكره يبدا بعض الاطراف الدوليه
بالتفكير في العقوبات هذا منهج عقيم ومنهج
لا يستقيم اطلاقا في مثل هذه الاحوال
للاسف الشديد العقليه الغربيه والتي
تمثلها الولايات المتحده والاوروبا
وبريطانيا هي عقليه لا تفكر الا فيما
ممارسه العقوبات وكاننا في فصل مدرسي
نعاقب طفل او تلميذ يعني خرج عن الصف هذا
امر يعني لا يستقيم اطلاقا في مثل هذه
الامور نحن مع دكتور نحن مع ضغوط نفسي
ولكن العقوبات نحن نتحدث بان السودان بوضع
اقتصادي حرج جدا بان اكثر من ثلث السكان
هم بحاله فقر وجوع والانسه يتطور ويتقدم
العدد مع القتال الدائر وبالتالي لا يمكن
التغاضي عن هذا الموضوع لانه سيؤثر على
الداخل سيؤثر على ثوره جديده من قبل الشعب
السوداني على على الاوضاع
اختي العزيزه موضوع العقوبات هنا موضوع
ملتبس للغايه الاوروبيون حينما يفكرون في
العقوبات يتصورون ان هذا الامر
يعني هذا امر خطير ايضا وهذه نقطه ضعف
كثيره في الموقف الاوروبيه والمواقف
الامريكيه وانا اقولها بصراحه ليس الان هو
موقف التاكيد يعني التفكير في عقوبات سواء
على افراد او سواء على مؤسسات او سواء على
بلد التفكير الان هو اقناع الطرفين بان
يتوقف عن اطلاق النار وان يفكر في الحوار
من خلال مبادره يكون فيها نوع من انواع
التنسيق بين كل الاطراف المتدخله في
الازمه السودانيه هذا هو الحل العملي لا
تستطيع ان تقول لاننا
بالتاكيد علينا ان نفرض عليهم هذا النوع
من الاقتناع نفرض عليهم هذا النوع من
الضغط السياسي والمعنوي والدبلوماسي هذا
الامر هو المدخل الحقيقي الان التفكير في
العقوبات لا يجب ان يكون هو الاساس الذي
تحاول الولايات المتحده او بريطانيا او اي
طرف اخر ان يكون هو في مقدمه الاشياء طبعا
هي الاداه التي ستستخدم نحن نحاول ان
نحافظ على السودان وليس نحاول ان نضع
الضغوط على السودان والسودانيين علينا ان
نفكر في مساعده السودان وليس في اذلال
السودان والسودانيين واهانتهم ويعني نوع
من انواع وضعهم تحت صاله العقوبات التي لا
اساس لها ولا امل منها سيكون الخيار اذا
محل اذا حال رفضت الاطراف المتناحره
الجلوس والاستماع الى المطالب الدوليه
والاقليميه شكرا لك الدكتور حسن ابو طالب
المستشار
الاهرام ايضا الاستاذ انتهى الوقت
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه من
القاهره
التغطيه
مشاهدينا ايضا طبعا مستمره ساعود الى ضيفي
بالاستوديو استاذ يعني استمعنا الى كل ما
يحدث على الارض وكل التحليلات الدائره
ولكن هناك نقطه ساتطرق اليها معك قبل ان
انتقل الى الزملاء موضوع تحميل بقايا نظام
البشير فلول الاخوان مسؤوليه ما يحصل الان
على الارض ويعني
صح التعبير
احداث الانشقاق بين الطرفين والذهاب الى
مواجهه لماذا وكيف لعبوا دور بهذا الموضوع
طيب ممكن بس اجاوب على مساله الفرض
العقوبه
العقوبات في 2021 عندما تم الانقلاب
العسكري وحصل موت للشباب في الشارع
السودانيه مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اصدرت
قرار بانه يمكن يتم محاكمه
البرهان وحمتي بشكل مباشر اذا الموضوع ليس
عقوبات ضد السودان بينما ضد العسكريين
الذين يمارسون تلك
الافعال البشعه على الشارع السوداني هذا
ما اتوقعه في المرحله القادمه قد اذا
استغصى الامر في اتفاق الطرفين يتم فرض
الشرعيه عن عن الاثنين تماما بموضوع
فلول الاخوان
وبقايا نظام البشير كيف لعبوا دور
بالتفريق والاقتصاد بين الطرفين بالتاكيد
لن نستطيع ان نجزم تماما ولكن بالتاكيد
القوات
لا اريد ان اسميه فلول ولكن هذا ما
تستعمله يعني الجهات الداخليه السودانيه
هذه القوات بكل المقاييس موجوده يعني
حكومه يعني بيسموها ايش الحكومات العميقه
او الدوله العميقه الدوله العميقه موجوده
في كل المواقع السياسيه في السودان في كل
مواقع العسكريه وبالتالي قد تكون وحدي من
التحركات التي قامت بها تلك نرجع نقول
الفلل باشعال هذه الفتيل الازمه
اكيد اكيد هنالك من قاموا بهذا هنالك
مصلحه والمصلحه هي عوده
الاخوان المسلمين او مؤتمر وطني الى
المشهد السياسي السوداني الذي يرفضه كل
الشعب السوداني في الوقت او معظم الشعب
السوداني الذين يعني يعانوا الكثير في
خلال 30 سنه التي كانت فيها تلك السلطه
سائده على الوطن وغيرت كل المفاهيمها
ادلجت كل مناحي الحياه شكرا لك دكتور
اسامه احمد المصطفى الكاتب والمحلل في
الشؤون الافريقيه على وجودك معنا داخل
الاستديو خلال هذه التغطيه
مشاهدينا التغطيه مستمره اختم معكم هذه
الساعه والان الى الزملاء طاهر بركه
وراويه القاسم ولكن بعد قليل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات